et
[Musique]
au delà des annonces c'est la réalité et
la réalité seuls qui intéresse les
français vous n'avez pas donné
aujourd'hui de garanties solides sur la
question des masques aux explications
sur ce sujet monsieur le premier
ministre ressembler davantage à des
excuses qu'en est il des respirateurs
ceux qui ont tant manqué à nos services
de réanimation ceux commandés par l'état
est manifestement inadaptées aux soins
hospitaliers pour le coc vide ce
nécessaire pour réarmer nos hôpitaux en
cas de seconde vague
êtes vous réellement prêt au delà des
mots dans les actes monsieur le premier
ministre nous devons testé massivement
les objectifs que vous venez d'annoncer
son minimaliste en termes de tests ils
ne permettront pas de généraliser le
dépistage de tous nos compatriotes
quelle que soit leur situation la
réalité sur ce sujet c'est que vous
renoncez à massivement tester des
français ces trois questions
les tests les respirateurs les masques
sont les questions les plus essentiels
de tout depuis des semaines votre seule
stratégie est celle de la pénurie
parmi les mesures que vous avez annoncé
il en est une qui concerne
particulièrement qui concentrent
particulièrement l'attention de nos
concitoyens il s'agit du déconfinement
scolaire parce qu'il touche toutes les
familles tous les âges tous les
territoires
parce que rien ne préoccupent davantage
les français que la santé de leurs
enfants
n'en doutons pas vos préconisations
seront examinés à la loupe la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation vous avez auditionné
monsieur le ministre l'éducation la
semaine dernière et vous nous avez
expliqué les grandes lignes du retour à
l'école rentrée pour tous sauf pour les
enfants contact avec des personnes à
risque
échelonné sur trois semaines par groupes
de quinze élèves quelques jours après le
président de la république annoncé le
retour à l'école sur la base du
volontariat
nous avions aussi entendu parler de
d'une rentrée pour les élèves en
difficulté
seulement si l'on ajoute à cela la vue
du conseil
scientifique préconisant la rentrée en
septembre
la confusion a atteint des sommets et le
résultat ne s'est pas fait attendre
les deux tiers des parents n'enverrait
pas au moins un de leurs enfants à
l'école c'est grave c'est grave parce
que plus de huit cent mille élèves ont
disparu des radars pédagogiques et ce
malgré le formidable engagement de la
plupart des enseignants l'arrêt face à
une telle crise sanitaire
nous avons fait le choix d'une
opposition responsable
exigeante et utile à notre pays vous
remarquerez monsieur le premier ministre
que vous avez un avantage sur nous là
vous avez eu 72 heures pour prendre
connaissance notre propre plan de
déconfinement vous nous laissez à peine
trois heures pour examiner le vôtre nous
déplorons cette crispation coupable il
ne comprenons pas cette antenne pan qui
aura un coût politique majeur celui de
braquer les oppositions à un moment nous
avons besoin de rassemblement et de
sérénité
il est d'ailleurs quelque peu curieux
que le président de la république
appelle à l'unité nationale et que dans
le même temps le premier ministre a soit
sur le parlement et la démocratie
devraient avant tout rendre hommage à
l'ensemble des possibles chefs
d'entreprise salariés fonctionnaires qui
font tourner ses services essentiels et
qui tiennent le pays debout depuis le
début de la crise cependant le
confinement l'état a multiplié les
mesures pour sauver des entreprises
ajustant régulièrement les dispositifs
regard des remarques du terrain et aussi
des remarques des députés en partie des
députés de l'opposition
le défi est maintenant devant nous il
est simple sauver toutes les entreprises
qui était viable avant le début de la
crise et à ce sujet je voudrais dire que
j'ai des cas mais dés n'étaient pas
tellement déçu sur ce point par votre
discours puisque vous avez à peine
effleuré la question des entreprises de
la nécessité de relancer l'économie dans
notre pays et j'attends de vous et nous
attendons de vous monsieur le premier ce
que vous preniez ce sujet à bras le
corps vous absolument annuler les
charges sociales et fiscales
mettez vous à la place du commerçant de
l'artisan qui voit des charges fixes qui
n'ont pas diminué
pas de chiffre d'affaires et donc voilà
qui voit une montagne petit à petit
grandir devant lui qu'il pousse devant
lui et qu'il n'arrivera pas à gravir
demain si on ne veut pas voilà que des
entreprises
bien ferme après avoir été sauvé dans le
temps du confinement pendant le temps du
confinement économique il nous faut
absolument les accompagner et comme le
disait damien abad avant moi il faut
absolument annulé ses charges sociales
et fiscales
le prendrai que ces rebondissements
multiples nuit quand même à la
crédibilité de la parole publique
je me pose la question de savoir si
c'est la dernière version est ce que
mais il n'empêche que depuis le 23 mars
nous sommes dans un état d'exception un
état exorbitant du droit commun et il
apparaît important de se préoccuper des
libertés individuelles et collectives
car on n'a pas simplement toucher un ou
deux éléments notre droit positif
ce sont des pans entiers qui ont été
bousculés de droit social de droit pénal
de droit de la sécurité sociale du droit
des collectivités locales etc et des
obligations
ce sont des grands principe à valeur
constitutionnelle qui ont été
chamboulées la liberté d'aller et de
venir de circuler ce n'est quand même
pas rien et nous allons avoir deux mois
de pouvoir des sections d'exception
supplémentaire jusqu'au 23 juillet avec
comprenez que ce débat sur les libertés
individuelles et collectives soit un
débat important qui préoccupe l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens
il faudra insister aussi monsieur le
premier ministre sur notre souveraineté
numérique
il ne sert à rien d'avoir un serveur
national si le traitement des données
est fait à l'extérieur
s'agissant d'un débat manqué comme l'on
dit d'une occasion qu'elle ait manqué le
groupe des républicains s'abstiendra
dans sa grande majorité non qu'ils
s'opposent au principe de votre
déconfinement mais il ne peut vous
accorder sa confiance ni son soutien sur
la foi de quelques engagements par trop
généraux qui aurait mérité un examen
parlementaire plus approfondie et donc
plus démocratique
je vous remercie
[Musique]